thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you doing
my favorite part is the lunch tray
aspect yeah it's the jalapeno cheddar
sausage I believe it is this is the
regular sausage and then this is
jalapeno last time we talked about
Cooper's Barbecue having trouble finding
good barbecue places out here so I was
like you know what my friends at Coopers
they were like we gotta you just yeah
we're my favorite guests okay
we got like brisket we got ribeye we got
sausage guys talk for a little bit and
I'll be oh
I wish I had enough for everybody sorry
it was is from Coopers and this is next
door to Billy Bob's is that where we
were talking about last time right uh
according to Billy Bob's I never had
this well the first time for everything
now you can go back oh my gosh it's so
good guys
so wait you're from St Louis with some
barbecue like there St Louis has great
barbecue my brother my brother is a
barbecue artist he's got this huge egg
that can smoke for like 12 to 24 hours
oh my mouth and then just rib tips
falling off the bone but this this is
tasty too so you know respect to Texas
it's all good okay it's all good I love
the competition is good and remember
that drives Innovation right absolutely
drives you'll keep water
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
guys I'm going home
[Music]